No
we recently went to TGS in Tokyo that's
what the T stands for ETGs dave didn't
know thanks a lot to play Capcom games
including Resident Evil 2 remake which
is long awaited remake of a legendary
game and I another place you never
played so that's the angle we're gonna
take for this preview so how did it
actually feel because from my
perspective someone who's played every
game in the series it kind of the thing
that first stuck out to me was the way
movement fell and it feels a little bit
it's like a half step between Resident
Evil 5 and 6 where you have this kind of
like super almost action game style
control of the character the ant is like
and and the classic games where you're
still quite restricted in the movement
how did it feel to you Elysa it is very
reminiscent of those games it does take
a lot of like nods to the way you moving
like a third-person action game but I
think because it's a Reza game the
movement is still very deliberate you
can't just run and bounce off walls and
like and dodge you still have to be very
careful with how you move but it's I
mean it's way better than my opinion in
there like the tag controls is a lot
smoother does give you a lot more
freedom and the action feels like a bit
more intense could you like a bit closer
to it so one of the things you mentioned
there was tank controls and the reason
why people they are defenders of tank
controls myself included and a bunch of
Resident Evil fans out is because it
allows the developers the kind of
choreographed scares better because you
can control the way the player moves and
it's often slow and quite plodding it
builds up that tension when an enemy
suddenly like ambushed yeah and
similarly we've like the fixed camera
that's it they like fixed camera angles
and tank controls kind of go hand in
hand right how did it feel did it still
feel scary and Atmospheric with the be
kind of like over the shoulder camera
and land of like the fluid movement and
generally being able to really zip about
the environment yeah like it that was
definitely still of a lot of tension to
it like that you lose I get going from
like an over-the-shoulder angle instead
of having things hidden in like a fixed
camera perspective you're now like more
consciously checking corners the way you
check doors like
the way when you walked up to a door
you'd like slowly open it so you can
kind of like look through a crease I
found those moments really tense and
because the camera angle is like sticks
on your shoulder you can only see like
percentile of the room so it's those
those transitions were some of the most
tense moments and while you've got the
moves talking for about the flashlights
because when you aim with your gun and
when you're going into a darkened area
you get flashlight out any move when
your camera the only moving your
character makes is going to effect that
light and I found things like like I
walked past like a houseplant and that
the torch would like just that be
interrupted for a brief minute but that
small movement close to you is then
amplified into like something completely
different against the far wall then your
imagination scope I mean like
so for some context we played the Leon
stuff that has been showing out a bunch
of trailers and then we played the
claire stuff which starts off in the
garage area of the glass stuff that we
had that we did was at Gamescom yeah
that was the fight with william birkin
yeah
the disc is a direct continuing
continuing so at the end of that demo
you meet chief irons and he kind of
kidnaps Cheri Burcham and then from that
point on is where we took over and
eventually you play through the you kind
of it play in that environment to get
out of the garage area and then going to
like the police chief's quarters and the
thing that I kind of like really stuck
out to me and which is what you said was
they kind of what it loses in control
camera angles and kind of like being
able to place the character the player
in specific points to scare you it kind
of makes up for in a general like
pervading atmosphere it felt very
claustrophobic
I mean you paid more but I watched a
bunch of it as well and played a bit of
it that's the kind of thing that it
seems to be going for way more as a
whole the entire game but you know when
you played scary games you've always got
that kind of sensation of like something
behind you yeah with the fixed camera
angles you don't really have that
because you can see what's everywhere
but obviously the new camera angle I
found myself constantly looking behind
me not having any relations the first
games I didn't know where to kind of
expect enemies I'm since way different
but I didn't know like it's there gonna
be a liquor behind me is there gonna be
a zombie around this corner that that
new dimension of movement and like sight
lines was like like a 360 sphere of fear
instead of looking down and being scared
of something
[Music]
like the thing that got me was what you
said like I got unsettled by hitting
reload and as she really reloaded she
put her hand past in front of the
flashlight and something flickered up in
front of me and I was like oh no it's
just me reloading and the things the
expectation that you talk about there it
like you don't know where even in
someone who's played the game now
doesn't know where the enemies are going
to be because they've mixed up how
they're playing with expectation quite a
bit like in the Leon section there's the
iconic moment where you go into a
corridor and then you meet the liquor
that doesn't happen in this time round
and the liquors are kind of like
shuffled around as our enemies so like
it's it's clearly they've they've
understood what they're losing in the
remake like in modernizing it and making
up for it in different ways one of the
things that I'm really interested in
hearing about is how did the puzzle
elements of it feel because it for a lot
of people who are just looking at they
see an action game or they know Resident
Evil as an action series but this kind
of like is a throwback to a classic
Resident Evil series where like seven
puzzles are a big deal how did that feel
to you it was I mean like I'm a massive
baby when it comes to horror games so a
part of me didn't like it but like a big
part of me can bloody respect it because
it was forcing me to places where I was
seen as like I don't want to go there
man like I don't have to backtrack to
find this place because there might be a
zombie and I've only got two bullets and
my knifes nearly broken it was that that
kind of force like you need to find this
to advance instead of like like some of
the older horror games I've played or
something I've been forced to play on
this bloody channel a lot of them was
just solvable by like dashing past
enemies and like just like nothing up
and just sprinting forward where is this
for me again like being like one of the
few Resident Evil games I've played
especially the classics it was adding
like an extra layer of pacing for me so
instead of like blurted out jumps or
like all instances of fear I was
constantly being like this is a whole
place where I don't want to be and these
damn puzzles are keeping me here
that's that's one of the really
interesting things that I've found of
playing the remake it's kind of they're
going back and re-establishing or
reusing the rules of survival horror
that a bunch of them they created and it
really makes you appreciate what they
did for survival or on what Resident
Evil has done for survival horror that
element of doing a puzzle in in this
game back in the day it just felt like
doing a puzzle this is another thing now
and you know you've got experience and
you think about game design a little
more like you understand that this also
works to keep you in an area that you
don't want to be in and it kind of like
creates that even pacing where you've
had a fight with an enemy or encountered
a liquor and now you're doing this thing
that's going to bring you down a bit so
then eventually it's gonna you know rat
you up and scare you again what really
really loves one thing that was really
powerful from se7en as well was their
use of sound and now with the to remake
they've been able to use sound to a much
better the great yeah because it's it's
more directional from where your
character is right rather than like the
fixed perspective we've talked about
the other thing that's exciting for a
veteran and also for someone who's not
new to it is like they're fleshing out
clerestory it's it's a way more
different than it used to be before it
was like a lot there was a lot of
parallels between Leon scenario and
Claire scenario and they crossed over
here and there but it seems like there's
more unique stuff in clear scenario and
that means there's more opportunities
for storytelling so we've got a bunch of
like exploration of chief ions as a
character in the short demo we played
you pick up like an official police
magazine and they're like oh this guy is
real great right if you're the city yeah
and they're like really singing his
praises and then as you kind of get out
of the garage and go into his his
quarters you can read notes from him
where he's clearly wrong and he's been
up to no good and he's been dealing with
weird shady organizations and really
like treating his staff poorly so like
that's really exciting as well so it
seems like they figured out a good mix
of all the new and exploring new
territory that will keep like longtime
fans engaged so I think we can both
agree like where we're very excited
about this yeah I'm looking forward to
playing Resident Evil 2 for the first
yeah I mean like I played a bunch of it
and remix as with most fans like they're
they treated with a little bit of like
apprehension but I am way more confident
about where they're going with this I
absolutely adored Resident Evil 7 and it
kind of reignited my passion for the
series and it made me want more in that
classic Resident Evil style instead of
in like 20 years as well it's been a
long long time and this this game
definitely feels like a good mix of like
modern and classic Resident Evil so I'm
very very hard to play more and you
should be hype too but if you want to
kind of build that hype you can go to
youtube and Gamescom and watch some of
our gameplay videos we've got old ones
we've got new ones we've got impression
pieces keep an eye on the site as well
where we've got previews of the game as
well as an interview coming up in the
meantime you can find us on twitter i'm
at more h i'm at a regular dave and
keep don't bite anything I don't think I
view as a zombies yeah and part from
maybe sandwiches like food generally I
know I was going I don't even care the
game and I know this is going comeback
I've got something to say
that was too close you were almost a
Jill sandwich you're right